مرحبا بك سيد رضا كنا في الاستماع لكلمه
احمد نجيب الشابي والموقف الكبير
بالمطالبه برحيل الرئيس قيس سعيد الموقف
المتطور من القوى السياسيه المعارضه
للاجراءات الاستثنائيه والمطالبه بالحوار
والطريق الثالث الذي يتحدث عنه مثلا
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل يتحول
بالنسبه لكم في جبهه الخلاص الى رحيل الى
اين وما هو البديل بالنسبه لكم
بسم الله
السيد احمد نجيب الشيبي لرحيل قيس سعيد هو
في خريطه الطريق التي اقترحتها جبهه
الخلاص وهو الطريق الوحيد لانقاذ البلاد
عبر تنظيم انتخابات رئاسيه ثابته باوانها
وتنظيم حوار وطني لانقاذ البلاد وبالتالي
جبهه الخلاصه القصيره الاساسي في المعارضه
اليوم
في اذاعه عين اليوم هو العقبه امام اي
حوار
هو يرفض كل الدعوات وهو
يثبت طريق الهروب الى الامام وبالتالي لما
ناصر لانقاذ البلاد الا برحيله اما
بالنسبه للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
والمنظمات الاخرى فلهم مبادره في ث سلام
بيصور التكوين نحن نحترم همم هذه المبادره
لكن الجبهه تمتلك من خارج تاريخ التي
رسمها اليوم رئيس الجبهه في خطابه عند
انسداد المظاهره
او بشكل رئيسي تتحدث عن الانتخابات
الرئاسيه
مبكرا هذه الجماهير التي يشارك فيها
اليمين واليسار وكل يعني اطياف اغلب اطياف
الشعب التونسيه هل بنفس المستوى تتفق او
همم تشارككم هذه الرؤيه الاحزاب السياسيه
الحديث عن انتخابات الرئاسيه مبكرا رحيل
قيس سعيد هل تستطيع الاحزاب السياسيه
التونسيه التوافق على رؤيه الخروج من هذه
الازمه
هو لا تتفق جميعا احزاب والمكونات
والمجتمع المدني على رحيل قيس لكنها تذكر
اليوم على المازق الذي تعيشه البلاد وعلى
ضروره الانقاذ وضروره العوده للمسار
الديمقراطي وضروره غلق قوس الاستبداد
والحكم الفردي وهذا ايجابي جدا بعد سنه
السنه الفارسه في اربعه اجسام من السنه
الثالثه كانت الجبهه لوحدها واعرفه
الانقلاب اليوم
الاكياف الاغلب الابيض السياسيه هي من اجل
العوده التي مقرئيه اغلب المكونات المجتمع
المدني ينادي بالعوده التي وقعتيه واغلبها
تنادي بحوار وطني لانقاذ للبلاد تختلف
المسارات تختلف همم التمشي يختلف لكنها
تلتقي حول
بتاع حول حمايه مكاسب الثوره واهممها
الانتقال الديمقراطي حريه التعبير استقلال
القضاء همم التفريق فسولات والانتخابات
النزيهه التي فرث فيها قيس سعيد واستولى
على جميع السلط واصبح همم يسلك تاريخ
الهروب الى الامام رايناه البارحه في تونس
وهو في حاله هذا همم
وارتباك الكبير وبالتالي نحن نعتبره انه
لم يعد قادرا على تفكير البلاد ولا بد من
المرور الى الانتخابات الرئاسيه سابقه
لاواني